During the peak of coronavirus
pandemic in Sri Lanka,
that is mid 2020,
I came up with a surprising way
to fill my life with bliss and grace.
A magical mantra was nurturing
in the garden of my mind.
It felt like all good thoughts
that I have planted in my mind
has begun to blossom
into something beautiful.
This magical mantra was like a magic pill
for all perceived suffering,
which not only affected my life
but everyone else connected to me.
Thirty-eight years of my life,
I went on a self-seeking journey,
finding, who am I?
I went through a conscious dying process,
letting go of everything
attached to my name:
well-established career as a coach,
a charity consultant,
hypnotherapist, energy healer,
intimate relationships,
attachment to family,
12 years of well-established business.
So what was this magical mantra
that transformed my life for better?
"Thank you" were the two simple words
that filled the space between my ears
like a music in my head.
This was experienced profoundly
during the pandemic,
as everyone connected to me
was filled with fear
and doubt and anxiety,
and I had to do something different.
The first thought came to my mind,
first thing in the morning as I woke up,
was, "Thank you."
And the last thought occupied my mind
when I went to sleep at night
was, "Thank you."
I was thinking, "Thank you"
when I ate, when I drank, when I worked,
when I walked, sat silently,
when I consumed every man-made material.
It was like a music in my mind.
Sometimes I said
the word "thank you" loudly
even to inanimate objects
like sun and the moon and the stars,
birds, butterflies, trees,
little creatures in the garden
as if I was greeting them.
When you say "thank you,"
it creates a harmony between you
and the external condition
under observation.
It helps you to bring
your attention inwards.
It may be initially just a word
running in your head
without a true feeling
of gratitude in your heart.
A word is a sound,
and a sound is a vibration,
and vibration creates energy.
So when you keep thinking, "Thank you,"
after a while, that energy
start penetrating
into your heart center
and the rest of the body.
We cannot do much about troubled times
and conditions in life,
but we certainly can do something
to calm ourselves during troubled times.
Human mind is like water.
If it gets affected
by external conditions,
it creates movement
and you cannot see the depth.
This magical mantra, "thank you,"
and the true feeling
of gratitude in your heart
can help you deal with any life situation
peacefully, joyfully and blissfully.
May all beings be well, happy,
free from all suffering
and be enlightened.
Thank you.